what is up everybody its Anna Mac and
welcome to another episode of the week's
best anime videos which is a weekly
newscast about anime the links are in
the description recommendations go in
the comments I was actually going to
upload this video yesterday but we had
another video come out yesterday the
Code Geass updates video and I'll be
honest I thought you guys might not be
ready for a double upload double up or
take this week we learned that Goku from
the Dragon Ball series is going to be
one of the cultural ambassadors for the
2020 Tokyo Olympic Games along with
other iconic anime characters like
Naruto Astro Boy and Sailor Moon now
this is a huge deal you don't get much
bigger than the Olympics and this is a
clear sign that anime is quickly
becoming mainstream which is both good
and bad on the one hand anime going so
mainstream could mean that the content
that's being produced is going to be
catering towards a mainstream audience
that anime is going to be come to
Hollywood and so on but on the other
hand the fact that anime is becoming
mainstream and a globally recognized
entity means that people are no longer
going to be ashamed of admitting that
they like anime they're not going to be
hiding their love for anime and that
means that our community is going to
grow which is definitely a big positive
I know that quite a few people have been
made fun of in their lives for liking
anime in school and that kind of stuff
that we call dweebs on the internet and
I think that this is a sign anime going
more mainstream is a sign that this type
of stuff might change which is good
again people are gonna have more
confidence to get into anime and to
admit that they are anime fans and to
join our anime communities which is
awesome and if you need more proof that
anime is going mainstream this week the
Dallas Mavericks on official NBA team
shared on their social media a skit
where one of their players seems to go
super saiyan so a Dragonball Z related
skit on their official social media page
again this is clear evidence that anime
is becoming more mainstream and socially
accepted in the US and around the world
and that is big news for the anime
community in other news we finally have
a date and time for the epic ram versus
emilia best girl showdown that's going
to be live streamed on black Critic guys
channel the showdown is going to take
place on Wednesday
February 15th at 4:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time and it's going to feature
myself and Briggs from all-day anime
defending the honor of Amelia against
anime recon and black credit guy who
will be defending the honor of RAM
trust me you won't want to miss this so
be sure to subscribe to black credit Guy
and stay tuned for some epic anime best
girl drama
this week our friends Macklin on and
simply Rose posted more videos from
their visit to G anime on anime
convention in Gatineau Quebec I really
like these videos Mac posted our review
of the con and some vlogs and Rose
posted vlogs to in a really cool
showcase of the cosplay at the con so be
sure to check out those videos the links
are in the description and yes if you've
seen the thumbnail that is indeed makkal
not cosplaying as Menma from an Ohana so
be sure to check out those videos you
won't want to miss that
get cook uploaded a new video this week
and it was called if anime studios were
people and I mean this video was
hilarious like most of the books videos
I really liked it and I especially like
the dynamic between guy necks and
trigger that was my favorite part of the
whole video definitely check this video
out if you haven't already and I have to
say gig is really showing off with his
production quality lately I mean he's
doing a great job awesome work dude this
week WatchMojo uploaded another anime
top 10 list and this time it was a top
10 biggest what the [ __ ] moments in
anime as an anime fan I found this
interesting I could really appreciate
the points that were making and I can
definitely appreciate a good neon
genesis evangelion reference so I
definitely recommend checking it out and
finally our boy anime recon uploaded a
top 10 action romance anime list this
week but the unique thing about how
anime recon makes his top 10 lists is
that they're actually a.m. V's he
doesn't talk on these videos he just
includes music and plays scenes from the
anime in a really cool way so actually
I'm featuring this video as my favorite
a mV for this week you have to watch
this video it's like a top 10 list and
the really high quality and the all
rolled into one
I love the music that he chose to do I
loved his editing in this video
great job bro keep it up and that's it
for this week guys if you enjoyed these
videos be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]